BoBonsoir. La crise du logementn
vava en parler. Il y a l'aspecte
popolitique étais quand même asz
cocorsés depuis hier et ce matin
jeje vous fais entendre d'aborde
mamatin Monsieur Legault qui n'a
papas digéré ce qu'il a vu dans
- - J'ai encore des amis qui sot
dede la classe très moyenne
cocommentaires-là.
- - Une heure après période de
ququestion ne s'est pas apaisée.
- - Ma question c'est est-ce qul
reconnaissait oui ou non une
crcrise du logement.
- - Le nombre une incubation de
loloyer à trois chambres et plus
c'c'est un des plus bas. Je ne
cocomprends pas pourquoi ce
prpremier ministre-là ne veut ps
rereconnaître qu'il y a une crie
dudu logement.
- - Mon gouvernement à augmenter
leles montants à l'aide socialee
fafaçon historique. On a mis 600
mimillions d'accès logis on estn
trtrain de réparer les dégâts de
MoMonsieur Couillard car il a dt
ququ'il créerait 15 000 logemens
ababordables et même la députéee
VaVaudreuil a dit, il ne les a s
coconstruits. C'est le président
sisi nécessaire d'en faire plusn
vava en faire
- - Parlons d'abord de
l'l'interprétation de Monsieur
LeLegault. Monsieur Legault est
chchoqué ce matin.
- - Oui il était fâché parce que
dadans le fond de voir partout n
lele qualifie de déconnecter de
teterrain. C'est quand même son
ididentité politique, sa marquee
cocommerce. Il savait qu'il sert
prpris à partie. Faisait longtes
quque les parties d'opposition
avavaient une opportunité
d'd'attaquer Monsieur Legault sr
soson propre terrain. Monsieur
LeLegault a semé le doute. C'est
bibien possible que Monsieur lee
sasavait pas le prix d'un loyer
mémédian. Avec ce qu'il nous a t
c'c'est aussi possible qu'il
paparlait des étudiants, il est
dadans la pandémie depuis plus
d'd'un an. Il a le bénéfice du
dodoute ce soir.
- - Madame massée parlait des
ététudiants et lui a dit dans ma
ttête je parle de la part d'un
ététudiant dans un appartement
cocollectif. Michel David sur la
réréaction de Monsieur Legault e
mamatin car avez-vous pensé?
- - Évidemment pendant des annés
etet la accusé les Couillard
d'd'être déconnecté. Alors se
fafaire renvoyer la balle ne lua
papas plus. Je peux comprendre
c'c'est embarrassant. Je suis ps
dadans la tête de Monsieur Legat
alalors qu'il passait vraiment x
ététudiants, que Martin dit je e
susuis pas certain. Mais Monsier
LeLegault c'est un homme politie
d'd'expérience, il connaît les
mémédias, il devrait savoir quea
clclé appartenir il faut
kikilomètres tout ce qu'il est
imimportant. Pour des étudiantsa
cocoûté 500 $ la résulter. La
fafaçon dont il a formulé les dx
ininterprétations se valent.
- - C'est vrai que c'est un peu
amambigu et on ne peut pas être
dadans la tête de Monsieur
LeLegault, mais ça reste que coe
PhPhilippe Couillard allait où l
s's'était retrouvé à dire une
fafamille de quatre ans pouvait
fafaire l'épicerie avec 75 $
sasavait frapper l'imaginaire cr
cece n'est vraiment pas beaucoup
d'd'argent. Est-ce que Monsieur
LeLegault va réussir à compter
vavaincre tout le monde que
c'c'était pour un étudiant en
cocollocation?
leles diodes ignorées que ça coe
bebeaucoup plus cher que ça pare
quque c'est vraiment un problème
mamajeur depuis plusieurs jours
dedes articles dans les journaux
ouou à 900 $ des taudis avec des
cococktails de la moisissure. De
nonotarié public il y a un enjeu
mamajeur de ce côté-là.
- - Retour de table Martin. Son
acacceptation qu'il y ait une
crcrise du logement. Monsieur
LeLegault est prudent et ne veut
papas accoler ce mot-là. De
nonombreux reportages sur le fat
ququ'il y a déjà égorgé par la
papart de leur budget qu'ils
memettent dans leur logement.
PoPourquoi ne pas reconnaître ce
momoule à?
- - Ce que Monsieur Legault a dt
cece qu'il pense que ce qui se
papasse actuellement est dû à la
papandémie. C'est le dossier de
QuQuébec solidaire et Québec
sosolidaire le mène, c'est ça qi
enen elle, c'est sur ce son
teterritoire. Monsieur Legault t
foforcé de faire un effort parce
quque la tout le monde réalise
ququ'il y a un problème de
lologement. Ce n'est pas juste à
MoMontréal, obobjet de la malade
MaMadeleine 0 % le taux
d'd'inoccupation. Ce que Monsier
LeLegault a dit qu'il ne veut ps
inintervenir auprès des
prpropriétaires, il est prêt à
dodonner de l'aide directe aux
fafamilles qui en ont besoin por
boboucler leur budget. De toute
fafaçon il n'y avait rien dans s
cacartons de la CAQ sur ce temps
jeje la lis même pour les
lilibéraux.
- - Si tant est qu'il y avait ue
inintention d'agir à courte tere
cece n'est pas évident qu'elle
auaurait fallu qu'on encourage s
enentrepreneurs à créer des
édédifices à logements se
coconnaisse et plus. On fait des
cocondos en fait des maisons. Me
s's'il voulait AGS qu'il a un
esespace pour agir?
- - Monsieur Legault a démontré
ququ'elle connaissait pas bien e
dodossier. Ça a commencé cette
hihistoire-là que le ministre
reresponsable de l'habitation
MaMadame Laforêt a donné une
enentrevue à la presse ou d'abod
elelle n'y est qu'il y avait une
crcrise d'autre part de toute
évévidence elle ne comprenait ps
l'l'aboutissement de la dynamiqe
dudu logement. Monsieur Legault
dadans ses explications hier à
l'l'Assemblée nationale, disons
quque son explication était
papassablement simpliste. Le
QuQuébec s'enrichit en rattrape
leles autres provinces, c'est
nonormal que le prix des loyers
susuive. Alors à partir du momet
ouoù il comprend mal le problème
ilil est clair que la solution
n'n'est pas évidente à ses yeux.
ElElle ne l'est pas non plus à s
yeyeux. Même si on bâtit des
lologements et tout ça va sortir
dede terre dans X années. Aucun
prproblème d'ici juillet ça rège
ststrictement rien. Est-ce qu'il
fafaut geler les loyers comme en
OnOntario?
ilil y a une crise, Monsieur
LeLegault peut l'appeler autremt
mamais il y a un problème il fat
ququ'elle règle.
- - Comment doit-il agir?
- - C'est vrai qu'en ce moment n
esest dans une situation
exextrêmement tendue. Imaginez l
n'n'y a même pas encore,
l'l'éducation était beaucoup pls
fafaible. Imaginez si on avait u
jujuste flot d'immigrants la. Il
fafaut trouver une solution mais
ilil n'y a pas de solution faci.
JeJe pense q que le problème vit
auaussi que depuis des années iy
a a une réglementation sur les
loloyers qui fêtent qu'on en bât
papas. Qui fait qu'on rénove ete
reretrouve avec des appartements
ququi sont dans un état
lalamentable. Les propriétaires
cocomplets blâmés c'est difficie
popour eux de récupérer l'argent
ququ'ils investissent?
alalors peut-être que la solutin
sese trouve aussi de ce côté-là,
dede dire d'accord donnons un pu
dede lest permettant aux
prpropriétaires d'investir
dadavantage et donnons-leur la
chchance de faire plus de
rérénovations quitte à augmenter
lele prix des loyers. Pas de fan
dédémesurée mais tout de même.
MaMais contrôlons aussi davantae
leles augmentations parce que en
cece moment loyer ne peut pas
auaugmenter plus que d'un certan
momontant. La dernière le Grand
MoMontréal augmentation moyen
ététait de 4,2 %. Et pour les
lologements inoccupés augmentatn
dede 30 % lorsque le logement et
vivide le propriétaire se repred
mmême s'il n'a pas le droit. Les
gegens disent qu'on aurait créén
reregistre et tous les loyers ts
leles montants devraient inscrie
lala. On serait en mesure de
lilimiter cette augmentation là
imimportant. Mais ça ça fait, e-
cece que c'est la bonne solution
avavoir. Je pense qu'il faut
rérétablir un équilibre. Le
prproblème reste entier.
- - Le dire oui c'est vrai que
popour des gens ça peut être un
drdrame de reconnaître sa peut-
êêtre les solutions ne sont pas
évévidences mais de reconnaître
quque ça peut être extrêmement
didifficile.
- - C'est d'autant plus difficie
quque le marché ne s'auto régule
papas. Les gens manquent de
lologement. Désactivanant dire t
papas grave je le prends pareil.
DeDe ce moment-là c'est sûr qu'l
enen a qui n'entrouvrant pas.
- - Comme je le disais avec
MoMonsieur Bobin Monsieur Dubé
acachevait notre métaphore le cl
sese dégage soleil qui arrive.
MaMaintenant va revoir le
cacalendrier. Appel à tous, 14 i
niniera les 18 24. Ça plus vitet
quque prévu.
- - Oui il était vraiment bien
cocontent d'annoncer écouter le4
mamai les 18 24 ans ça va viteÇa
veveut dire que ça va bienen pet
totout le monde va avoir sa dose
enen fait tous ceux qui veulent
êêtre vaccinés auront
prprobablement leur première doe
avavant le 25 4 juin. Occulte
susuccès jusqu'à date
- - On l'a vu mardi. Je n'avais
jajamais vu Monsieur Legault aui
opoptimiste. Souvenez-vous il ya
dedeux semaines lave le moral ds
leles talons. La Monsieur Dubé
nonous dit aujourd'hui on est en
trtrain de gagner la guerre. Çaa
trtrès bien aux yeux du
gogouvernement et ça va
obobjectivement bien la
vavaccination dont rôle à un trs
ququ'on n'avait pas imaginé.
EnEncore une fois qu'on se compe
àà l'Ontario c'est vraiment pas
lele paradis mais enfin ça v vas
bibien. Et l'objectif du 24 juin
vava être très probablement
dédépassé. Malgré ses malheurs
dadans notre dossier Monsieur
LeLegault de quoi se réjouir.
- - Oui et nous tous. Ça roule
bibien. L'horlogerie de la
vavaccination est bien.
- - Oui le Québec est en avancea
prprovince qui a vacciné le plus
dederrière la Saskatchewan.
MaMaintenant ce que je trouve
inintéressant c'est qu'on arrive
dadans une tranche d'âge ou
vrvraiment sont des travailleurs
ququi devront être vaccinés. Trs
bibien que les employeurs mettet
l'l'épaule à la roue. Il y a
d'd'autres entreprises comme
d'd'Olymel qui me donne des bons
dede 50 $ si vous faites vaccinr
dede la la première dose 25 de a
dedeuxième dose. Il y a toutes
sosortes de stratégies, la caroe
ouou le bâton. Les employeurs qi
vovont décider d'être plus
rerestreints TIFF ça ne s'étaiet
papas vaccinés?
jeje pense que là ça va être aux
ememployeurs de faire leur part.
IlIl y avait Gabriel Nadeau Dubs
ilil il y a quelque temps qu'ils
écécoutent d'avoir congé payent
cocomme aux élections. Mais tout
dede même je pense qu'il y aurat
lilieu pour les employeurs d'ête
flflexible et d'être conciliante
cece c